une élection présidentielle à l'issue
incertaine en équateur le 11 avril les
électeurs devront choisir entre le
banquier conservateur guillermo olaso et
l'économiste socialiste andrés araoz
arrivé en tête au premier tour la
gestion de l'épidémie de coronavirus est
un enjeu majeur dans un pays à la traîne
sur la campagne de vaccination est où
l'état d'exception a été rétabli la
semaine dernière dans huit états à
écouter les habitants de quito la
capitale
difficile de prédire quelle sera l'issue
du scrutin honnêtement je préférerais
voté blanc mais espérons que quel que
soit le candidat il offrira le
changement et les possibilités d'emploi
dont les équatoriens ont besoin la
situation dans le pays est vraiment
grave à cause de la pandémie et tout le
reste
et oui nous les équatoriens pensons
qu'avec un peu de chance le nouveau
gouvernement qui entrera en fonctions
fera quelque chose pour tout le monde en
particulier le vaccin mais il devrait
vraiment être pour tout le monde car
nous connaissons les cas de corruption
qui existe avec les vaccins vip
le président rafael correa les serveurs
étages et nous devons le suivre dans
l'héritage de travail un héritage
d'espoir et c'est ce que nous les
équatoriens voulons la crise sanitaire a
aggravé la crise économique dans le pays
fin 2020 le pays d accuser une
contraction de 7 28%
face à ce constat demander à nouveau un
prêt au fmi est devenu une nécessité
mais le fonds monétaire voudra en
contrepartie prolonger une politique
d'austérité qui a déjà conduit à une
mobilisation sociale en octobre 2019
les manifestations avaient fait 11 morts
et environ 1300 blessés lors du mandat
du président sortant lenin moreno
l'ancien président rafael correa défend
lui son dauphin andrée zarauz et sa
volonté de réviser le pacte conclu avec
le fmi
ce n'est pas une relation avec le fmi
qui a été rétablie
l'asservissement ce n'est pas que nous
nous sommes retirés nous avons posé des
conditions
nous avons signé un accord avec le fmi
et nous devons rendre des comptes même
si c'est un peu ennuyeux mais nous avons
signé pas mon gouvernement mais nous
avons des obligations en tant qu'etat
mais si liliane en tant que membre de la
famille royale ne nous les renvoyons
dans le même avion en disant nous
n'avons pas eu ces missions de type
royal et nous avons fait mieux que
jamais il y a un an et demi lenin moreno
avait dû renoncer à ses engagements
d'austérité auprès du fmi
face à la contestation populaire mené
par les indigènes au premier tout en
février le mouvement indigène est arrivé
troisième de l'élection
plus que jamais c'est sur leur vote et
leur approbation qu'il faudra compter